[Musique]
pas parce qu'on ira à la pêche qu'on
serait arrivé toi et moi on va à la
pêche mon trésor sur eux qu'on soit venu
ici d'être en famille allez bocio
commence à faire froid elle n'est pas à
l'intérieur tylar
alors elle est où
nous prions le ciel pour que notre fille
taylor nous reviennent bientôt saines et
sauves suis vraiment désolé pour ce qui
est arrivé à votre fils l'affacturage
pourquoi vous parler d'elle au passé
la police dit qu'on peut participer aux
recherches cette nuit ici me rends tu
avais fait diversion pour permettre à
sanary d'autres
je crois qu'il est temps pour vous et
madame michael sohn d'aller dormir à
l'hôtel il n'est pas question que je
parte tant que ma petite fille n'est pas
revenu près de moi saine et sauve à
on devrait participer à labatut nous
aussi
il faut prévient la police il sera parti
en retraite
gfr
[Musique]
au sud du lac ils ont retrouvé la
dépouille d'un campeur
nous sommes des meurtriers
il faut qu'on reste unie face à tout ça
il nous resterait un paul des mois ce
qui nous rassure nos pays notre fille
[Musique]
vous ne devez pas perdre espoir
puis il ne faut pas non plus que vous
restiez coincé
cela vous entraînerait dans un cercle
vicieux
[Musique]
vous n'irez nulle part et or était aussi
tu sais que c'est eux qui l'ont enlevée
je sais que tu es vraiment je connais
tout et se craignent
pitié jerry
l'acceptation c'est aussi lâché prise
vous n'avez rien de nouveau à dire
[Musique]